problem 28
which equation best represents the part
of the graph shown below so we have a
bunch of equations here let's see this
one is just a linear equation so this is
just some number times x so that graph
in general would be a straight line this
one and this one are straight lines this
one would be a
a straight line with a positive slope
maybe look something like that this
choice c right here would be a straight
line with a negative slope
like that they would both go through the
origin because they they don't have any
y-intercept right there so neither of
these are the answer so let's just look
at these two i guess we could call them
quadratics so here we have 1.75 x
squared the graph of anything so the
graph of x squared if we if i let me do
it in a better color
the graph of x squared looks like this
looks like this it's a parabola you've
seen that before and they're just
drawing it in the first quadrant right
there and that looks about right and
you're like hey but what about the 1.75
well that's just a scaling factor if you
throw a larger number there it'll
curve up a little bit faster if you
throw a smaller number there it'll curve
up a little bit slower but the general
idea is that they all have the general
shape of a parabola so this one looks
pretty good it's an upward opening
parabola it's a kind of an uh uh upright
u so this looks like a pretty good
solution if we were to draw the whole
graph it would continue off on this side
like that
a choice d it's just like choice b
except they have a minus here and the
reason why i know that's not going to
work is that if the graph of
minus x squared or any or minus anything
times x squared is going to look like
this
it's going to look like that it's going
to be downward opening so this is the
graph of
minus x squared the graph of minus 1.75
x squared
might open up or go down a little bit
faster it's going to have the same
general shape so we know that this is
also not the right answer so our choice
is
b
next question
lisa typed a 1 000 word essay at the
average rate of 20 words per minute
20 words per minute
if she started typing at 6 20 pm and did
not take any breaks
at what time did lisa finish typing the
essay so she had a thousand word essay
and she was typing at 20 words per
minute so let me write that down so she
had a thousand words
a thousand words
and she's typing at 20 words per minute
so if you you're writing a thousand
words and you're doing 20 per minute how
many minutes is it going to take you
well what's a thousand divided by 20.
you could do this in your head you say
100 divided by 20 is five a thousand is
ten hundreds so it's going to be fifty
but if you don't wanna do it in your
head you could just say twenty
goes into one thousand
twenty goes into ten zero times twenty
goes into a hundred five times five
times 20 is 100 and then you bring down
the zero
20 or or you bring down the zero i guess
you could view it that would bring that
20 goes into zero zero times and then
zero times is zero and then you are done
20 goes into a thousand fifty times so
you could say two goes into a hundred
five times all the same thing so this is
twenty and then the word sorry fifty i
wanna be careful
so it'll take our fifty minutes and
actually the units work out you have
words divided by words per minute or
that's the same thing as words times
minutes per word they cancel out and you
end up with 50 minutes if that confuses
you don't worry about it too much the
intuition is what's important you had a
thousand word essay you did 20 words per
minute so it's going to take you 50
minutes 50 minutes times 20 words per
minute is equal to a thousand words so
you're going to have 50 minutes
minutes
so she starts at 6 20 p.m
so 6 20.
so at 7 00 p.m
at 7 p.m she's worked for 40 minutes
that's 40 minutes right because there's
60 minutes in an hour so she but she
works for 50 minutes so she does another
10 minutes so she does another 10
minutes so that gets her to 7 10. so the
choice
is d
problem 30.
what does let me do it in red
what does x to the fifth equal when x is
equal to
minus 2 so it's minus 2
times minus 2 times minus 2 times minus
2 times minus 2. now we can just
multiply it all out and let's just do
that just for fun minus 2 times minus 2
is positive 4 then positive 4 times
minus 2 is minus 8
minus 8 times minus 2
is positive 16.
positive 16 times minus 2 is minus 32 so
our answer is a
now if you wanted to do that really fast
you might recognize well 2 to the 5th is
32 so it's either going to be that
choice or that choice and then we have a
odd exponent an odd exponent so we're
going to be multiplying a negative times
itself an even time
and then one more negative so you're
going to get a negative number when you
have an odd exponent you're gonna end up
with a negative if you had an even
exponent
even exponent you'll end up with a
positive so that would be the fast way
to do it but even if you didn't kind of
do that you could just multiply it
straight out like we just did and just
remember a negative times a negative is
a positive and then a positive times a
negative is a negative you get to minus
31 the graph below compares the weight
of an object on earth to its weight on
the moon interesting an object's weight
on the moon okay so this is the moon
weight this is the earth weight so
something that let's say well i actually
do weigh 150 pounds so i weigh 150
pounds on earth and according to this
chart i would weigh 25 pounds on the
moon or are we essentially one-sixth my
weight than i am on earth
so what is it asking me what is the
approximate weight on the moon of an
astronaut who weighs 120 pounds on earth
well i just said you essentially you're
just taking this thing is just taking
one sixth and you know you can look at
any point when you weigh 10 pounds of
the moon you're weighing roughly
you're weighing roughly 6 60 pounds on
earth or or or vice versa so you just
take one six or we can actually just
look at the chart 120 pounds let's see
if we go halfway that's about 125
between 100 and 150 120 pounds will be
right there
you go up the graph just like that
and you go there and it looks i don't
know it looks like 18 or 19
pounds and they say what is the
approximate weight so the closest thing
we are here is you have a choice of
15 and 20. we're definitely closer to 20
than we are to 15. so i will i will go
i will go with 20 right here and you
know if we really wanted to look at it
this was actually the point that we
should have looked at and this point
right here
would have been 120 pounds but you just
approximate where 120 is go read the
graph and say oh it's closer to 20 than
any of these other choices so that'll be
our answer